again zach keplin ninth start 3.86 era
not a great outing his last time out
five runs over six but
he went six again one-o and chisholm
swings and pops it up
out into left field andrew mccutchen
drifting in he's waiting and he'll make
the catch
rojas swings at the first pitch i think
that's going to happen a lot tonight for
both of these pitchers
segora under it two outs here in the
first
and a fly ball out to right field harper
started back comes in and that one's
gonna fall
back-to-back two-out hits for the
marlins in aguilar with two outs off on
the crack of the bat ends up at third so
here's dickerson
after back to back two out hits goes
from first pitches hit in the air to
center fields
herrera is right there at the beginning
is over 17 pitches
what a year it's been for trevor so far
five and two 184 era
he starts the night fourth in the
national league and earned run average
all four walk them on four pitches
oh two pitch swung on grounded towards
first aguilar he's got it steps on the
back throws down to second and rojas
with the tag
and rogers has his first strikeout
tonight
scoreless after one and he added a few
points to the batting average last night
with his first multi-hit game since the
17th of april
and he goes the other way this time and
this
is gonna go a solo holder to start the
second
for brian anderson now welcome back ba
we've been missing you
good to see that philly brings a smile
to your face
great career numbers in philly great
career numbers
against the phillies swing of the miss
threw him a curveball
first curveball in the night and then
odubal was number five
rogers tried to check did he go and
yes he did says the home plate on fire
he even asked for help on that one
rhys hoskins leading off pops one up
brian anderson waiting for it to come
down that's out number one
that's right back to him able to get
leather on it
and there are two away hops he gets five
stars for me
huge fan you'll be able to hand out
those stars
when we come back knapp grounds out
one-nothing marbles
swag and a miss that curveball's moving
right now
three strikeouts for f1 there's the 2-2
swinging a miss he got it change up
that's four for effluent
four out of the last five
bouncer to shortstop big hop for thereas
and a one two three in it
the team batting average for center
field right
and a line drive base in it to left
field he's hitting eight consecutive
games and now 12 of 13.
first hit of the night for the phillies
2-1 pitch
and a line drive base hit it to left
field and that's where preparation pays
off
and there is a strikeout on the fastball
1-0 is a bouncy ball right side jazz has
it sidearms the first
and trevor's out of the inning nicely
done
hit hard aguilar is there he will race
to the bag and beat harper by a step one
down
however there is one more game against
the phillips brian anderson fields
throws to second for one on the first
it's a double play
swing gonna miss five k's for flint
wow smokes one and what a play by rhys
hoskins
reese is ready that's full extension
oh boy that was full extension
and a cold strike three got the inside
part of the play beautiful pitching from
zac
eflin he had six strikeouts in the ball
game
one on a nap is a line drive to right
coming on duval and he makes the sliding
catch that's cooper
three and two they'll check
it sounded like maybe a click click i
don't think anybody agrees
on what just happened now he herrera's
saying it hit him
right the marlins who said he swung at
it or it was a strike
and the home plate umpire is claiming it
was a foul ball that was caught
by leon
coming in and that's 101 not the miles
per hour but the strikeout number
he gets a couple in the fifth one
nothing
two or two and that's going to get down
to the left field corner
rojas is going to turn and head towards
second base mccutcheon gets it in but a
stand-up
lead-off double here's adam duvall now
runner on third less than two out 2-1
pitch
is ripped on a line base hit left field
duvall delivers
miggy's in to score it's two-nothing
marlins adam duvall knocks in his 30th
run of the season
sandy leone pounces on it throws to
first and the strikeout of mata
so that is now six strikeouts
cuts tonight over one walk and a
strikeout
mccutchen launches one deep to left it
is gone back row
just at the foot of the liberty landing
the phillies are on the board it's a 2-1
ball game mercy following a strike
on rogers first and second
butcher boy base hit
and the bases are loaded
first major league hit for trevor rogers
way better than a bun
way better bases loaded and jazz
chisholm in the box
out in front of the plate stays fair and
he got around it cooper got around the
tag
and the marlins take a 3-1 lead
bouncer out to shortstop they can come
home with this one they do there's one
and that's all they'll get but they do
get the lead runner the ball hit into
three for the marlins
popped up what a pitch over at third
infield fly roll has been called batters
automatically out with a fair ball
runners lead off in the o2 pitch to
duvall swag and a miss he got him
[Applause]
one and two on the way to hoskins pokes
it out to right it'll stay up for
cooper one away payoff pitch to bones
swinging a miss 97
eighth strikeout for rogers andrew knapp
rounds one left side backhanded by miggy
throws and got him trevor rogers was
going out to work in the eighth inning
for the first time in his career
two on with nobody out and brad miller
is coming up owen two coming to miller
ground ball can they turn it that's one
on the first to double play
the longest outing of his career really
impressive
mccutchen stands in with a rudder in
third here's the 1-1
hot smash caught on a dive by rojas
saved a run and gets this one to the
ninth what a play
he's in scoring position the tying run
is coming to the plate
and now reese hoskins coming up it's
coming
back toward the middle and chisholm gets
to it throws off balance to first not
in time phillies bring the winning run
to the plate
alec balm that's the one you're looking
for
beats him with a fastball and there are
two away in the ninth
and now it's left to andrew now garcia
comes home with it
and knapp with a fly ball out to deep
right center field
at the wall sierra makes the leaping
catch
it's a marlins win
[Applause]
they win it by the skin of their teeth
knapp can't believe it marlins hang on
three to one
had it the whole time